[Music]  blac chyna wishes Rob Kardashian a happy  birthday we're all in a good place the  29 year old reality star took to  Instagram stories on Saturday to send  her well wishes to her ex on his 31st  birthday posting this snap of the pair  with their one-year-old daughter dream  which they share joint custody of Rob's  little one was with him at mom kris  Jenner's house for his birthday  festivities Kris celebrated her only  sons special day sharing at this  adorable collage captioning the pic in  part it brings me so much joy to see the  incredible father you have become I am  so proud of you Rob's sisters Kourtney  Kim and Kendall also shared sweet posts  in honor of their brother I love that  [Music]